faut-il oui ou non construire de
nouveaux réacteurs EPR voilà la question
qui aurait dû être posée hier à tour à
l'occasion du grand débat public sur le
nucléaire voulu par le gouvernement une
réunion finalement annulée ce qui n'a
pas empêché les Antilles de faire le
déplacement il dénonce un débat tronqués
les la Turquie
une retraite cette fois pour les
centrales nucléaires des slogans candés
dans les rues de Tours par près de 130
manifestants les collectifs sont venus
de tous les horizons pour s'opposer à la
relance du nucléaire en France on le
présente le nucléaire comme énergie
verte comme une solution à la crise du
climat alors que la crise du climat est
engendrée par la société industrielle et
capitaliste on est là pour dire STOP
pour dire on va arrêter ça mobiliser
malgré l'annulation des deux dernières
réunions prévues par la commission
particulière du débat public le but
initial échanger publiquement sur les
projets de construction de nouveaux EPR
en France une suppression des débats
expliquée par l'adoption au Sénat le 24
janvier d'un projet de loi bien
spécifique permettant l'accélération des
installations de nouveaux réacteurs si
on les construisait il serait
opérationnel au mieux en 2040 voire plus
tard étant donné les délais de
construction et que de toute façon le
climat ne peut pas attendre 2040 il faut
mettre tout ce cet argent qu'on met dans
le nucléaire dans autre chose dans
d'autres solutions alors par quoi
remplacer la première source de
production d'électricité en France les
manifestants table sur les énergies
renouvelables et un mode de vie moins
énergivore la surconsommation d'énergie
par rapport au petit gadgets qu'on a etc
c'est une catastrophe mais aussi à la
grande échelle industrielle et
collective donc il faut réduire
évidemment notre consommation et puis
ensuite il faut tout miser sur les
énergies renouvelables tout en
réfléchissant est-ce que ces énergies
renouvelables ne soient pas imposées à
la population et ne soit pas faite dans
des conditions qui dégraderaient
l'environnement
si les réunions publiques sont annulées
le débat continue en ligne jusqu'au 27
février pour un compte rendu attendu fin
avril